oh no no no no hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to escape the
Isle walkie ok so guys problem right off
the bat right off the bat we got
problems ok big problems right off the
bat this is a horror game in which the
IU walkie the are you okay
the I yeah
the iuo key can hear me that's not good
cuz that's like the main thing that I do
is yell hey bass I'm very loud but I'm
gonna try to play this game but in doing
so I'm probably gonna have to be real
quiet I don't know how this is gonna go
I honestly have no idea so we're gonna
find out I guess I don't know if I
should shut up now or if I should is
there gonna be like an intro sequence or
am I gonna be blabbering my mouth off
and just suddenly the I you walk he's
gonna crawl up my ass and then blow me
up like ant-man did to Thanos hello
okay so supposedly I'm in a safe place
for a safe pace place right here so the
aisle walkie the I you okay
the I yeah so the ayaya can't come kill
me okay I think I'm fine I've got to be
fine
this place gives me the creeps
should I talk okay
I'm gonna test the limits here just
gonna real gently
okay okay I'm in a safe space I think
I'm I'm not a hundred percent sure where
I can talk and where I can't talk yet so
everybody just bear with me because I'm
not too comfortable where I am right now
I'm just gonna go from safe space to
safe space talk real quietly to myself
and then go from there
hello hello hello
hello I don't trust you I don't want to
I really don't want to I rather not okay
[Music]
how many keys do I need in this place
that was a mistake
okay so I got some weird clock pieces I
thought that door was gonna bid
[Music]
what the [ __ ] was that I thought it was
gonna get be I thought for sure who's
gonna get me yeah I thought it was gonna
get me eat me alive though who's gonna
give me the uh a yacht okay so I'm gonna
move god this is scary
[Laughter]
alright I'm just gonna move on make it
to the next location
just be
oh my god [ __ ] didn't look me in the
goddamn eye that thing looked mean no
look right I made it look right yeah
this might be one of the scariest things
I've ever done
that there's something about this that's
just so viscerally scary I hate it I
hate it I hate it okay here we go guys
that's weird it looks like this goes in
the clock I'll put the pieces on the
clock so that's good I hate it I don't
know what you are I got ya I don't know
what you are I don't know
I put the bees on the clock there's got
to be some kind of a puzzle to that but
I don't know what it is it suck I hate
you I hate you okay okay here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I can go nowhere I can go nowhere
guys I can't make it like five feet
without it come on Joe can i okay so I
think the music helps me I think the
music that's gone on Lana
I think that helps me because it blocks
up the sound that he would ordinarily be
hearing from me snip stepping and yell
yawning all the way down the hallways
[Music]
[Music]
so I don't exactly know how far I need
to go but it seems it seems like them
the more noise comes from the
environment as opposed to my big
blabbermouth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is insanity this is insanity I
don't know what this game wants for me I
know I'm supposed to get some kind of
red key
I can't make it five feet oh my god to
get a red key if I can't make it five
feet go [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you -
[ __ ] this is this is I don't know where
I'm going I don't know what I'm going
for it I don't know where I'm going I
don't know why I'm going forward I don't
know anything I don't know anything at
all I just gotta find a red key and I
don't know where that is okay but I
think it's okay where am I now I was
pointing the wrong way keep happening
[Music]
I was trying to soul in my sniff I gotta
be a brave man boy men at some point
I've got to be a brave man lay you suck
you suck my mouse foot me around my
mouth flipping me around my mouth it
feed me the wrong way all right fine you
know what screw you
I got Yahoo okey I'm gonna I'm just
gonna I'm gonna run screaming through
your halls I don't care no unnecessary
stuff but you know
[Music]
so what did that do was it sister troll
so it only goes to the most recent noise
I okay either my mic isn't working or
he's stupid oh he's not stupid
oh he knows he knows
I don't know how to beep okay those
don't make noise
funded I'm dead I'm dead I'm so dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead
why are you for my mouth God okay
alright alright okay I'm not gonna be
bested by you game I'm not gonna be
bested by you
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to cautiously but quickly move I'm gonna
make noise back away from the noise
source let him pass right by I'm
guessing you can hear me talk I think
that's I think I think he can hear me
yeah I'm pretty sure he can hear me talk
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
shut up
so home alone
[Music]
good fine yeah you better run
dotty popped up right there I didn't
know this was a hidey hole maybe there's
more hidey holes and I think there are
like right back here there's so many
more hidey holes Lebanon okay you can't
get me one time in a hidey hole hey hey
[ __ ] you ugly [ __ ] you stupid piece
of poo you dumb ugly brute you dumb dumb
dummy you dumb dummy dummy you dummy
once I'm in here I am immune
I'm immune mmm you stupid idiot
[Music]
man he just randomly goes places he
loves to just go I love to go I love to
go forward forward going is my favorite
so forward going I will do I'm learning
the limits guys I'm learning the limits
it's it's a doozy it's a doozy to learn
the limits [ __ ] you man
ha [ __ ] you ha screw you buddy
yes like there's no ending ok I'm
learning the limits guys learning the
limits
[Music]
he's real zippy but there's lots of
hidey-holes
lots and lots of hidey-holes
so that's good considering there's lots
and lots of hidey holes that means that
there's never too much distance between
me and a new hidey hole which means that
I won't die I was gonna make it thought
I was gonna make it thought I was gonna
make it I thought I thought I've the big
thought big thunk errs thought I was
gonna make it I did not make it turns
out funny enough I didn't make it
weirdly wumbly this is not a hiding spot
[Music]
just the way he charges at me when he's
on nila when he's in cryptid mode when
he does that I said I feel I get a
fight-or-flight response
it's I can't help it just block
you see that coming at you down the
hallway you ain't gonna panic this is a
little bit screams [ __ ] terrifying I
don't know it every time even though I
know it is oh my god
it's so scary it really hits the scary
button it just hits the blink you're
scared that's all it is they just a a
cower into a ball
I can't punch it so I got a tower
[Music]
[Music]
I don't want to know how close he was
behind me in that room I don't want to
know I would rather not know I think
what was the point of coming down here
who's the point of this what was the
point of this
oh are you are you at anytime and
anybody at any moment I could have just
crawled under there lost him at any
moment at any moment that's why the
clocks this should no no no no that's
why that's there that's why
[Music]
see you around buckaroos yeah can I get
under there
[Music]
okay so god damn you stupid noise
[Music]
okay so news I can jump
[Music]
[Music]
this did not help me at all at least be
careful I think you know what you're up
to
they may do something about it so you
must act quickly before they manage to
get away with the plans I won't tell
anyone what you're trying to do but
please I beg you as a friend another
thought think about everything we're
achieving and fanning with this and
everything we're losing if you expose us
[Music]
Colt someone say something about a Colt
like a murder colt
a Colt that wants to murder people dad
those are great thank God okay got that
out of the way there all right just want
to turn off your stupid radio you stupid
I yoki
[Music]
I guess he heard me talking [ __ ] white
white I was up other thing this mouse
why does it spin me why spin me why
would you spin me mouse I don't get that
it's weird random games that I play have
like 180 mode enabled
[Music]
I thought I was in there I thought I was
in the hidey hole I thought I shoved
myself in there I thought I squashed my
body down into the hole
good God game I don't know what I'm
supposed to do oh oh I didn't know that
I could I didn't know that I could
follow the my
I hate you I hate you I defy you hide
Yuki if that is your real name
ah I tried to leap over I tried to leap
over him and he just reached up bit into
my taint and pulled me back down to his
level okay
I have no idea I have no idea this is
like Finding Bigfoot the first time that
I liked Finding Bigfoot in that I have
no idea what I'm doing and I have no
idea why anything is happening but that
is escaped the IU walki if you guys know
how to paint this let me know or if you
want to play it for yourselves I'll put
a link in the description it's pretty
good like there's some primal fear there
there's a primal fear that is just so oh
why are you doing this like you just
really get caught up in it and it's
still pretty good though so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]